foreign
[Music]
developers build all sorts of
applications
Foundation models and apis make it easy
to start and develop these AI driven
applications to solve all kinds of
business challenges in this video you
will learn how you can leverage vertex
Ai and Lane chain to build generative AI
driven applications getting started with
a use case is easy let's say you want to
use a large language model
first step is choosing a model like the
vertex AI Palm API
then you design and write your prompt
after that you will check the quality of
the response and improve if needs
so far so good
but wait what if I have a more complex
use case
like one where I want to leverage
real-time data
or combine the power of multiple large
language models
well then we have to deal with some
challenges
Out of the Box large language models
only have access to knowledge in their
training data
what if you want an llm to use data it
has never seen before
like today's weather forecasting or the
latest sales data also there are use
cases where you need to orchestrate
multiple steps before getting the
desired outcomes okay let's look at some
common design patterns to help you
better understand this
so your first use case might be one
where you want to include data from
external sources like a database or an
API this way you can embed the latest
data in your prompt to help improve your
model's performance
another example could be a use case
where you need to do multiple calls to
your large language models to get the
desired outcome
like when you want to summarize large
documents
a third example could be a pattern where
one model's output goes into the next
chaining multiple models together
but how can you implement these patterns
well there are different ways
one you can write boilerplate code to
stitch it all together
another option is using a framework as a
layer of abstraction and orchestration
one of these Frameworks is line chain
link chain is a framework that offers
flexible abstractions that developers
can use to build lln driven applications
Lang chain enables applications that are
data aware so connecting a model to
other sources
agenda allowing a language model to
interact with its environment
so how does Lane chain fit with vertex
AI as you may know vertex AI gives you
access to Google's genitive AI to build
AI powered applications
vertex AI offers integration with the
Lang change python SDK making it
convenient to build applications on top
of architecture
vertex Ai and Lane chain have
Integrations for services like
the vertex AI Palm API for text chat and
embeddings
vertex AI Vector search
and vertex AI search
also as you may have seen at Google
Cloud next where enabling the ability to
click to deploy lunch and applications
to vertex UI with vertex AI extensions
this means that you don't have the
hassle of having to spin up and manage
your environment stay tuned for more
introductions to come okay it's time for
some code
let's look at a basic example on using
the Palm API and Lang chain for
summarizing large documents
first to use the vertex AI Palm API and
Link Chain you make sure that the vertex
Ai and Link Chain SDK are installed in
your environment
next you have to import the libraries
from Lang change and lamps you will need
to import the vertex AI class
then set the text spice model as our
default because it's great for
summarization next you will have to
create your prompt templates
that you will use as pre-defined recipes
this example uses Lane chains mapreduce
method
to implement a multi-stage process to
summarize large pieces of text by first
summarizing smaller chunks of text and
then combining those summaries into a
single summary after defining the
templates you initialize the associated
mapreduce chain and then generate some
range using the chain
this will generate the summary
okay now how can this help you as a gen
AI developer
using vertex Ai and Link Chain can
accelerate your genitive AI development
lifecycle
where length chain is an abstraction
layer
you can build many use cases like
improving customer support through a
chat interface that leverages llms
explore fast amounts of unstructured
data through conversational interfaces
and summarize large documents to consume
information faster and many more okay
let's wrap this up in this video you
learned how can you use vertex high with
link chain to build generative AI
powered applications and how to use the
vertex Ai and Lang chain SDK integration
to build Solutions check out the link
below to learn more about genit API with
vertex shy thanks for watching and
definitely let us know in the comments
what you are building with generative AI
[Music]